in der ampelkoalition sind die roten und
die grünen gelb vor neid wie die gelben
die liberalen das hingekriegt haben mit
einer mischung aus unverfrorenheit und
härte das bisherige
infektionsschutzgesetz nahezu
wirkungslos zu machen die meisten
vorschriften fallen weg und das
ausgerechnet in dem moment in dem die
inzidenz werde neue höchststände
erklimmen und neuinfektionen täglich
steigt
rekordzahlen bei kronach lockerungen um
jeden preis jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst im studio ist hier schimke für
die cdu im bundestag
und sie sind stellvertretende
vorsitzende der mittelstands-union
matthias niewels bei uns der
stellvertretende gesundheitspolitische
sprecher der spd im bundestag und auch
mitglied im gesundheitsausschuss
zugeschaltet sind christina berndt
wissenschaftsredakteurin
der süddeutschen zeitung und der
virologe und epidemiologe professor
klaus stören sie waren früher leiter des
so genannten globalen influenza
programms der
weltgesundheitsorganisation die hv
schimke geht denn ihr sehnlichster
wunsch am sonntag in erfüllung
also wenn ich die diskussion jetzt
verfolge so wie wir sie aktuell führen
dass schon wieder gewarnt wird dass auf
die steigenden infektionszahlen
verwiesen wird obwohl wir inzwischen
wissen dass omikron lange nicht mehr die
gefährlichkeit hat die korona 1 x hatte
dann gehen meine wünsche gewiss nicht in
erfüllung ich sehe natürlich auch dass
kinder in schulen weiterhin masken
tragen sollen dass landesregierungen
ohne die feststellung einer epidemischen
lage weiterhin masken schlicht als auch
testpflicht verhängen können und das
macht mir schon sorge ob er jemals
wieder rauskommen aus dieser sind
ruhiger so mussten aber dass sie
eigentlich diesen koalitionsentwurf ganz
gut finden der morgen verabschiedet
werden bundestag und bundesrat also es
geht ja schon in richtung lockerungen
das muss man ganz ehrlich sagen aber
bitte schauen wir doch mal über den
tellerrand was macht denn das ausland
also die sind doch schon viel viel
weiter wie wir nur wir tun uns wieder
schwer ja jetzt endlich auch mal
loszulassen es nimmt uns doch auch
keiner mehr ab was dort gemacht wird ist
die bürger können es nicht mehr
nachvollziehen in tragen ist auch nicht
mit es ist ist vielen schlichtweg
einfach egal die menschen wollen jetzt
einfach kommune auch hinter sich lassen
und ich denke dass die virusvariante das
auch in der tat so lässt mich das jetzt
können sich möglicherweise auch in
manchen koalitionsfraktionen in ihrer
auch bei den bündnisgrünen manche schwer
mit dem was da vereinbart worden ist
deutschland kam ja bisher
vergleichsweise glimpflich durch die
pandemie im vergleich mit anderen
ländern wird das jetzt durch diese doch
sehr umfangreichen lockerungen aufs
spiel gesetzt nein denn wir gehen mit
augenmaß vor was die pandemie ist noch
nicht vorbei wir haben weiterhin hohe
instanzen allerdings ist es so dass die
krankenhaus belegung bei weitem nicht
auf einem niveau sind wie wir sie schon
mal hatten und deshalb weil wir die
situation haben dass an einigen stellen
wir besser unterwegs sind können wir
lockerungen machen wir können diesen weg
gehen aber gleichzeitig bringen wir ein
paket auf den weg dass zwei bestandteile
hat damit wir diese erfolge nicht
verspielen und diese beiden bestandteile
sind auf der einen hand die basis
schutzmaßnahmen das heißt wir werden
weiterhin masken tragen dort wo
schutzbedürftige menschen sind und wir
werden auch weiterhin testen und der
zweite bestandteil das ist die hotspot
regelung die die bundesländer weiterhin
nutzen können um dort wo instanzen sehr
schnell steigen dort wo neue varianten
kommen oder auch für das
gesundheitssystem in gefahr ist
zusätzliche maßnahme auf den weg zu
bringen das ist vorgehen mit augenmaß
diese beiden punkte werden wir im laufe
der sendung auf ihre praktikabilität
hinterfragen verband konnte selbst karl
lauterbach am ende den massiven
lockerungsübungen nicht mehr standhalten
ja so sehe ich es also karl lauterbach
hätte das mit sicherheit so nicht
entschieden wenn er denn das hätte
allein entscheiden dürfen dies ist also
ein rein politisch gewolltes datum aus
meiner sicht der freiheitstag hat wenig
mit der echten pandemischen lage zu tun
denn die ist ja gerade hat große kraft
wie wir wissen die welle wächst und
wächst wir haben jetzt 300.000
neuinfektionen pro tag also das ist
keine medizinische entscheidung jetzt zu
lockern sondern dass es ein politisches
versprechen was da eingelöst werden soll
von herrn buschmann aus dem letzten
herbst der eben an diesem tag nun die
freiheit verkünden wollte und es ist ja
nicht so dass die meisten menschen in
deutschland darüber glücklich wären
sondern umfragen sagen ja viel mehr dass
etwa zwei drittel doch noch gerne etwas
länger an den maßnahmen festhalten
würden auch viele bundesländer haben
sich beschwert dass sie sagen sie wissen
nun eigentlich gar nicht wie sie damit
umgehen sollen sie wollen eigentlich
auch länger festhalten und ich halte es
eben auch für sehr gewagt in diese phase
der pandemie hinein so zu lockern stöhr
masken pflichttests pflicht
abstandsregeln
hygiene-maßnahmen das wird alles
zurückgefahren ob eine impfpflicht kommt
es im moment auch eher unsicher werden
wir diese politischen entscheidungen in
dieser woche noch bereuen
ja ich habe die schere geht immer weiter
auseinander zwischen der realen beim
chemischen situation in dem was in den
köpfen noch angst existiert am
politischen willen da als tatsächlich in
richtung in den mitzulaufen sie haben ja
schon kurze ins ausland geschaut da
belächelt man deutschland bestenfalls
noch die situation ist im vergleich zu
den nachbarländern viel entspannter
deutschland hat das
achtbeste
krankenhaus ausstattung an wenn man die
betten waren nimmt weltweit schweden und
auch die schweiz haben nur ein viertel
oder nur die hälfte der
krankenhausbetten wie deutschland
deutsche haftbefehle intensivbetten wie
kein anderes land und trotzdem glaubt
man dass das sind das gesundheitssystem
hier noch überlastet wird bei inzidenz 7
ausland viel höher sind als in
deutschland also diese schere zwischen
realer pandemischer situation sorgen die
man haben muss in dem fall politisch
artikuliert wird und dann zum schlüssel
umgesetzt mit masken krieg den schulen
diese schere ist weit offen da würde ich
gerne an frau bands dies- und gleich
nochmal zurück spielen karl lauterbach
hat er gesagt die lage sei schlimmer als
die stimmung wenn man jetzt stört ist ja
die stimmung schlechter als die lage die
viel besser ist ist da diese schere
zwischen dem was in den köpfen vorgeht
ängste und der realität sehr groß
geworden
nein ich sehe das nicht so ich teil auch
die ansicht von herrn stern nicht denn
wir haben willich mehrere probleme es
geht ja nicht nur darum schwerste
krankheitsverläufe zu verhindern das
gelingt momentan relativ gut durch die
impfungen die wir haben und dadurch dass
omikron dann doch nicht ganz so
aggressiv ist wie etwa delta dadurch ist
es in den krankenhäusern für die
patientinnen nicht so schlimm aber man
muss natürlich auch sehen wie viel man
an anderen folge erkrankungen damit sich
zieht wir haben sicherlich viele longo
wie viele am ende unter denjenigen die
sich jetzt so massiv infizieren und wir
haben auch infiziertes klinikpersonal
das ohnehin schon am ende ist nach zwei
jahren pandemie jetzt fehlen da ganz
viele leute krankheitsbedingt so dass
die lage in den krankenhäusern schon
deshalb auch schlimmer ist also all
diese dinge sollte man nicht aus dem
auge verlieren wenn man öffnet und das
heißt ja nicht dass man nun aus dieser
schleife nie wieder herauskommt wie frau
schimke ist eben sagte sondern dass man
einfach jetzt noch mal sehr vorsichtig
ist bis dann hoffentlich in einigen
wochen das virus uns ohnehin in die
karten spielt in dem es sich in die
sommerpause zurück zieht wie es
eigentlich hat ja niemand mehr bock auf
pandemie und die einschränkungen die es
seit über zwei jahren gibt trotzdem gibt
es noch incidents werde es gibt eine
spezialisierung skate es gibt auch jeden
tag zwischen 200 und 300 menschen die
die nacht nicht überlegen mit oder an
cupid erkrankt es gibt ja auch spd
regierte bundesländer die das endliche
bernd sehr kritisieren was jetzt am
morgen im bundestag beschlossen werden
soll welche lockerungen sind denn gut
aus ihrer sicht und gibt es da auch
kontraproduktive ich frage jetzt nochmal
nach es ist ja ganz offensichtlich nicht
so ganz klar dass da alle einer meinung
sind dafür jetzt morgen genau das
richtige macht absolut wir haben eine
koalition aus drei parteien da gibt es
auch unterschiedliche meinungen und ich
gebe zu das paket was wir morgen auf den
weg bringen hätte ich mir noch ein wenig
umfangreicher gewünscht ich hätte gerne
wie viele kolleginnen und kollegen der
spd fraktion noch ein paar instrumente
hinzugefügt das sage ich ehrlich aber
ich muss auch sagen das paket was wir
machen damit kann man arbeiten
es wird uns helfen ein basisschutz auf
den weg zu bringen und auch zusätzliche
maßnahmen vorzusehen und dann haben wir
uns auch dazu verabredet wenn die lage
sich doch noch mal deutlich
verschlechtert wenn wir eine neue
situation haben sind wir auch jederzeit
bereit erneut den bundestag zusammen zu
holen um nachzulegen auch dazu haben wir
uns bereit erklärt verschiedene sie sind
der überzeugung dass es im herbst nichts
zu bereuen gibt wenn man auf diese
entscheidung geht es in dieser woche
zurückblickt dass man so viele
bestimmungen gelockert hat viele
menschen sind ja noch sehr unsicher
geplant hat er die entsprechenden
umfragen gerade zitiert ja gut aber wir
können ja nicht politik auf vorrat
machen nicht in so einer frage was
persönliche freiheitsrechte angeht was
den eingriff in die körperliche
unversehrtheit angeht wir sprechen ja
gleich nochmal auch über die impfpflicht
also wir müssen im hier und jetzt und
heute leben so und da gibt uns gerade
auch unsere benachbarten länder auch ein
stück weit den takt vor und das wir da
so hinterherhinken finde ich einfach nur
noch peinlich und dass wir ein
gesundheitsminister haben dem sowieso
kein mensch mehr glaubt der eigentlich
die absolute glaubwürdigkeit verloren
hat der geimpfte gegen ungeimpfte
gegeneinander ausspielt ja der sozusagen
auch angst in dieser gesellschaft schuld
wenn ich das mal so ehrlich auch sagen
darf das ärgert mich unglaublich gut
seitdem er bundesminister ist ist ja
auch einer koalitionsregierung
unterworfen da wissen die unions
politikerinnen und politiker genau was
das ist weil sie 16 jahre ja selbst die
bundesregierung mit gestellt haben
herr stöhr im moment und jetzt sind wir
gleich bei dem thema um das es geht
nämlich was ist was gilt jetzt ab dem 20
märz beziehungsweise nach einer
übergangszeit anfang april da geht es ja
auch um die belastung des
gesundheitswesens also die sogenannte
hospitalisierung 's rate die ist im
moment ziemlich niedrig wenn man sieht
mit dem letzten winter vergleicht
eigentlich muss man schon fast sagen mit
dem vorletzten winter
bleibt dies so niedrig können wir damit
rechnen dass selbst bei steigenden
incidents werten bei vielen
neuinfektionen die vielleicht noch durch
die decke gehen dass trotz denen das
gesundheitswesen nicht mehr so belastet
wird
ja in deutschland weiter nicht nur in
den köpfen paralleluniversum will sind
sondern auch tatsächlich das
gesundheitswesen anders belastet werden
würde dann könnte noch was anderes
passieren und allen anderen wird es halt
nicht passieren und das gesundheitswesen
schlechter aufgestellt dass nämlich
gleich noch eins hinzufügen zu der
diskussion noch maßnahmen aufrecht
erhalten die stelle nach hinten ziehen
wir haben in einer situation wo sich
jeder infizieren wird geimpften die
genesenen und mehrmals sogar noch
infizieren wird gleichzeitig hat sind
alle medizinischen
interventionsmöglichkeiten auf dem tisch
die es gibt das ist die impfung das sind
gute medikamente und das ist ein
stabiles gesundheitswesen alle diese
medikamente instrumente wirken nicht 100
prozent es wird also immer wieder
infiziert mit schwer erkrankt auch
todesfälle gehen dass es das beste was
wir rausholen können und der situation
wundermittel wird es nicht geben
wunschdenken wäre es das jetzt noch mal
toll ist anderes kommt es dort aber
nicht kommen außerdem stellten den
medikamenten in guten gesundheit werden
und damit ist klar
dass infektions ergebnis eines jeden in
deutschland jetzt schon kalt steht und
dass ich heute infizieren vier wochen
oder einem halben jahr ist das selber
die welt oder hat nicht geimpft und dann
können sie sich auf gesundheitswesen
medikamente und vielleicht nimmt aber
auch verlassen also deswegen gibt noch
eine zelle nach hinten zu verschiedenen
ändert an dem gesamtergebnis wegen
krankheit lag nichts mehr also
letztendlich die mathematiker sagen die
fläche unter der kurve ist gleich auf
die kowitz schlacht und lang ist also
den modellen angeschrieben oder spitzen
und stein und kurz das ist ein identisch
also jetzt noch weiter masken zu tragen
die nicht zu verhindernde durchseuchung
zuzulassen er heißt eigentlich nur die
schmerzen weiterhin nach hinten zu
verschieben natürlich wird es jetzt im
frühling auch an sich entspannter werden
gar keine frage und im herz wird man
meine winter welle geben wie hoch die
wird muss man dem sommerfest stellen
durch eine gute studie wie hoch die im
unglück aber das muss man sich vor augen
halten den mann immer wieder fordern
dass kinder jetzt masken fahren das
abstand gehalten wird dass gesundheit
werden es nicht überlassen mehr
möglichkeiten haben wir nicht und jeder
wird sich infizieren und die steht fest
was das ergebnis dieser entwicklung zu
jedem verband die ich habe wenn ich
solche gesetzlichen körper luft geholt
nur leider helfen diese infektionen eben
nicht ja es ist ja bei omikron eben
anders als bei bisherigen varianten also
omikron erzeugt bei menschen die nicht
geimpft sind eben kaum einen immunschutz
was sie jetzt sagen herr stöhr das würde
ja helfen wenn sich jetzt viele menschen
infizieren und man dann in den herbst
geht und die hätten dann alle eine
immunität dadurch auch erworben aber es
ist eben so dass zwar die impfte durch
omikron nochmal ihren immunstatus
verbessern und erweitern ungeimpfte
hingegen nicht die infizieren sich jetzt
mit omikron dann machen sie nur eine
sehr spitze und sehr schwache
immunantwort die können sich in vier
wochen in acht wochen schon wieder mit
omikron infizieren und sind dann auch
nicht besser aufgestellt und wenn andere
varianten kommen schon gar nicht also
leider trägt das nicht so im studio
themen wie unserer bevölkerung bei was
da jetzt passiert ja ich will natürlich
argumentieren zu der immunität von mir
und das ist nicht so ganz wasserdicht
plötzlich wagen aber nehmen wir mal an
das wäre so was wollen die denn dagegen
tun was dazu kommen die leute werden
sich nochmal infizieren in der hoffnung
natürlich haben wir alle dass ich viele
impfen lassen dann wäre das natürlich
die infektion auswirkungen reduzieren
aber wie wollen sie mit irgendwelchen
maßnahmen verhindern dass die leute sich
infizieren es geht nicht alle während
inspizieren
oder man kann sicherlich besser man kann
ihr könnt das nach hinten schrecken und
was passiert dann
aber für den einzelnen schüler die
unterbrechung tränen einzelne es ist
egal wenn er jetzt geimpft ist
einigermaßen mundschutz hat obwohl ich
heute infiziert und einem halben jahr er
wird entweder schwer krank gehören oder
mit frank wären ja irgendwie einen
mundschutz wieder ein wie die
ausgangslage ist die er mitbringt es
wird aber nichts an der eigenen am
eigenen infektionsrisiko len infektions
ergebnis ändern oder einen anderen
bildung
im moment ist das einfach so dass das
risiko wahnsinnig hoch es sich zur insel
dass man sich eben auch als variabler
mensch kaum schützen kann weil die
infektion so häufig sind dass man dem
virus eben momentan kaum entgeht setzt
wenn man alt und vorher krank ist wir
haben hier in der sendung die
beneidenswerte situation dass wir
ständig zwischen der experte neben und
der politischen ebene wechseln können
heute war ein treffen des bundeskanzlers
mit den ministerpräsidenten aller 16
ministerpräsidenten haben untereinander
getagt eine pressekonferenz mit dem
bundeskanzler da war
ziemlich deutlich dass offenbar viele
fast alle länderchefs sauer sind über
die vorgehensweise wie jetzt dieses neue
infektionsschutzgesetz dadurch gesetzt
vielleicht sogar durchgepeitscht werden
soll auch ihr parteifreund endlich löst
ministerpräsident von nordrhein
westfalen der ja diese diese verärgerung
sozusagen
sammelt und dann nach außen trägt hat
das massiv kritisiert es geht um diesen
basisschutz also zb die masten pflichtig
erheblich jetzt eingeschränkt wird
dieser ist instrumentenkasten wie heißt
dieser basisschutz instrumentenkasten
der ist eigentlich gar nicht mehr
brauchbar zur pandemie bekämpfung das
gegenteil von dem was eigentlich
abgemacht war zwischen der bundes und
der landesebene ist jetzt eingetreten
die länder sind ihre
bekämpfungsmöglichkeiten beschränkt so
hendrik wüst ist da der bund die
bundesebene da zu weit vorgeprescht ohne
auf die länder zu hören war das fällt
mir auf dass das werde ich schnell jetzt
durchgezogen war diesen eine richtige
politische diskussion auch in den
gremien hat sie offensichtlich nicht
gegeben also ich will nicht ausschließen
dass es da unterschiedliche auffassungen
in der tat darüber gibt wie man jetzt
vorgeht im übrigen ist das ja auch das
bild was wir von den letzten zwei jahren
haben machen wir uns nichts vor da war
nie irgendwie friede freude eierkuchen
und die große einigung nein die
meinungen gehen doch in diesem land
massiv auseinander
ja es gibt menschen die tragen auf dem
fahrrad eine maske ja es gibt menschen
die gehen andere an weil sie nicht
genügend abstand halten also das ist ja
schon verrückt was man so alles erlebt
im alltag klar und das ist natürlich in
der politik nicht anders da kommt jeder
auch zu einer anderen einschätzung
deswegen ist das ja auch eine
gewissensentscheidung ich kann das
durchaus nachvollziehen dass hier
sozusagen auch diese richtung gefahren
wird und insofern ist es okay ja wenn
man da auch eine andere auffassung
bezieht ich hab da auch meine
persönliche meinung und danach anleger
auch
in diesem instrumentenkasten weil wie
gesagt die masten pflicht allumfassend
jetzt in innenräumen die soll ja
zurückgefahren werden sie gilt jetzt nur
noch in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln und
inneneinrichtungen oder in einrichtungen
mit variablen gruppen also zum beispiel
in pflegeheime und krankenhäuser nicht
in arztpraxen interessanterweise obwohl
es ja eigentlich ein ähnlicher workflow
stattfindet aus der gleichen branche ist
das zu wenig hätte man die masken
pflicht noch erweitern sollen zumindest
eine zeitlang noch auf gastronomie oder
einzelhandel
wie schon gesagt ich persönlich hätte
mir eine erweiterung gewünscht
insbesondere wenn es um das masken
tragen in innenräumen geht sie haben
einige beispiele genannt wo auch viele
menschen zusammenkommen das wäre aus
meiner sicht sinnvoll gewesen wir haben
uns jetzt auf dieses paket geeinigt und
was man auch beachten muss es bleibt ja
nicht nur bei staatlichen maßnahmen und
einschränkungen sondern wir haben ja
eben laufe der pandemie alle dazugelernt
die arbeitgeber beispielsweise bietet
mittlerweile viel mehr home office an
das heißt selbst wenn eine home office
pflicht nicht mehr besteht haben jetzt
viel mehr menschen die möglichkeit von
zu hause zu arbeiten das ist gut viele
familien haben sich zu hause mit
ausstattung zugelegt haben der oma in
smartphone ein tablett gebracht dass man
auch dinge tun kann dass man lernen kann
dass man kommunizieren kann auch wenn
man nicht immer die möglichkeit von
treffen hat das heißt wir als
gesellschaft als ganzes haben sehr viel
dazugelernt wir sind resilient geworden
das ist ja auch ein großes thema
frontfrau band resilienz das haben bei
uns über die zeit angeeignet und das ist
gut und deshalb bin ich zuversichtlich
dass wir jetzt ein gutes paket auf den
weg bringen mit denen wir weiter
arbeiten können und wir haben im übrigen
auch gelernt schnell zu reagieren wenn
sich eine neue lage ergibt da drauf
setze ich die verärgerung der
ministerpräsidenten kommt ja auch daher
dass ja ganz offensichtlich diese
hotspot regelung also dass man das alles
wieder teilweise einführen kann wenn es
die pathogene situation also die
virenlast zum beispiel
notwendig macht oder wenn in den
krankenhäusern zu wenig intensiv betten
zur verfügung gegen die sind aber diese
diese hotspot regelungen sind rechtlich
nicht besonders exakt fixiert gibt es
bei den großen spielraum
da gibt es eine regionale
entscheidungskompetenz also jede region
macht dann mehr oder minder was sie will
auch die konkreten grenze hat man
bewusst weggelassen das befindet sich
alles auf rechtlich sehr wackligen füßen
das war ja auch die verärgerung der
länder chefinnen und chefs gewesen
warum ist es so weit gekommen oder was
hat man sich dabei gedacht ich würde
mich den begriff den sie gewählt haben
nicht anschließen ich würde als
flexibilität bezeichnen denn die länder
haben die möglichkeit als hotspots
einzelne städte oder auch kreise zu
benennen wie auch ein ganzes bundesland
das heißt es gibt freiraum für die
länder diese regelung zu nutzen dh sie
haben da auch gewisse
entscheidungsrechte das so zu definieren
wie es für ihr bundesland für ihre
regionen passt und im übrigen die
diskussion mit den ländern hat eine
konstante wenn der bund alles
vorschreibt dann bekommen wir die
rückmeldung hey wir wollen entscheiden
wenn der bund dinge offen lässt lässt
dann kommt die rückmeldung er sagt nicht
genau wie was machen sollen diese
hotspot regelung könnte am ende ja vor
jedem der 16 landesverfassungsgericht
landen denn wie gesagt man kann das
unterschiedlich sehen die rechtliche
situation ist nicht geklärt also egal ob
man das in detmold in schwedt/oder
nordweil macht möglicherweise wenn dort
die gebietskörperschaft sagt ja wir
führen bestimmte verschärfte maßnahmen
wieder ein wird dagegen geklagt und dann
das ist dann ein problem für die
verfassungsgerichte die sich dann
möglicherweise wochenlang darüber
streiten oder vor den gerichten
gestritten wird ob das jetzt wirklich
eine typische lage war oder nicht so ist
es und man macht sich natürlich auch
angreifbar auch innerhalb deutschlands
angreifbar die menschen diskutieren ja
die sehen ja was geschieht im
nachbarland und je nachdem wie die
persönlich die interessenlage geartet
ist nimmt man dann auch entsprechend die
argumente für sich nah und insofern das
wird wieder zu mehr streit führen ohne
frage
verband diese regelung die es jetzt gibt
die am ende des monats oder anfang april
in allen bundesländern dann auch gelten
wird gerade diese hotspot regelung
wie beurteilen sie diese möglichkeiten
werden die in der praxis tauglich sein
das hoffe ich sehr also ich sehe einfach
auch das problem dass flickenteppich
sehen wir dann wieder bekommen und ich
befürchte dass es eben manchmal
vielleicht doch zu langsam und so zäh
und zu ja mit zu zu großen
auseinandersetzungen führen könnte denn
was wir natürlich in der pandemie
brauchen ist eine schnelle
reaktionsfähigkeit also das ist das eine
was ich an dieser regelung kritisiere
und das andere ist dass ich den
basisschutz eben zu wenig ausgeprägt
finde vor allem fehlt mir tatsächlich
die masken pflicht in manchen
öffentlichen einrichtungen nicht wie ich
finde sie fehlt auch im einzelhandel
einfach dinge in drogerien in
supermärkten wo menschen auch hingehen
müssen selbst wenn sie besonders
gefährdet sind da kann ich einfach nicht
verstehen wie man ein so wirksames
instrument hier aus dem verkehr zieht
das hätte man einfach für alle weiterhin
verpflichtend machen müssen das wäre
eine bessere phase kommen er störe es
wird ja immer von eigenverantwortung
gesprochen die jetzt sozusagen die
vorschriften des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
ablösen soll weil sie haben es gesagt
eben die gefahr nicht mehr so sehr in
verzug ist aber eigenverantwortung heißt
dass ich so ziemlich alle daran halten
müssen und eigenverantwortlich sein
müssen ist da verlasse bei der
bekämpfung der pandemie dass das was
bisher das infektionsschutzgesetz
größtenteils übernommen habe jetzt von
der eigenen verantwortung der menschen
und zwar möglichst vieler menschen
übernommen wird
ja in anderen ländern hat man das von
anfang an versuchte mehr zu fördern
schweden natürlich haben skandinavische
länder auf ein anderes zusammenhalt
gefühl
entwickelt ich glaube nicht dass die
eigentliche verantwortung allein hilft
den situationen wohl tatsächlich
allgemeinwohl in gefahr ist aber noch
mal das allgemeinwohl ist nicht mehr in
gefahr die
gesundheitssituation ist relativ
entspannt im vergleich und lasse mich
noch eines sagen die diskussionsrunde
zeigt ganz deutlich wie gespalten das
verständnis noch ist sie so eine
pandemie zu ende kommt es geht nicht
mehr darum infektionen zu verhindern
also wenn jemand sorge hat dass jetzt
viele infektionen da sind dann läuft der
eigentlich dem pandemie geschehen um
monate hinterher infektionen mussten
nach hinten geschoben werden bis ein
impfstoff für alle zugestimmt jetzt sind
alle instrumente da alle wehren sich
infizieren alle infektionen die man
verhindert die können heute morgen oder
mit dem beiden effekte auch ein paar
monate später entstehen das muss man
immer wieder wiederholen es geht nicht
mehr darum infektionen zu verhindern was
richtig ihnen was ich gut findet dass
man auch die verantwortung für die
maßnahmen in die regionen delegiert
natürlich das politisch natürlich immer
hin und her geschoben der stadt später
dann soll er auch sehr gut erklärt aber
die anämie bekämpfung muss eigentlich
immer vor ort geschehen in deutschland
ist groß schauen wie man in österreich
noch über schweizer hat 87 millionen
einwohner das ist so groß wie nie in
einem anderen bundesland dafür dass auch
lokal entschieden werden müssen und die
welle läuft ähnlich systematisch durch
ganz deutschland durch das sieht man ja
auch gewonnen wie die hospitäler belegt
sind die auch die instanzen sind da gibt
es unterschiede da muss man dann auch
lokal reagieren für die situation
entwickelt und ich glaube da sollten die
länder regiert nicht beschweren die
haben ja vorher eigentlich immer auch
viele die jetzt beschweren haben ja
immer ihr eigenes ding dann noch durch
jetzt stört wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe baut ihre argumentation darauf
aus dass wir eine variante haben omikron
die zwar sehr ansteckend ist aber im
verlauf sehr milder sind sie sicher dass
im laufe dieses jahres zum beispiel
vielleicht auch wieder richtung winter
nicht wieder eine variante aufkreuzen
könnte wie delta die sehr viel
verheerender wirken kann
ja es gibt viele arten wechsel wären ag
noroviren renovieren rocker wie ein
autofahrer mit ihren mit abnehmen und es
gibt sehr gute erfahrung wie sich die
viren entwickeln in welche richtung dorf
gehen es gibt kein beispiel in der
geschichte dass ich einer der viren
wieder in eine höhere pathogene variante
verwandelt hat auch die wir und sie
kombinieren können also die genetische
information austauschen das gibt es
nicht was passieren wird definitiv ist
eine neue variante geht ihnen im mund
schritt unterläuft das gibt wieder
weiter influenza dann nur noch 50
prozentigen reduktion der im wirkung
führen dann muss man die impfstoffe
entsprechende anpassen bei der krone bei
den crooner und schon kann man das viel
schneller influenza wo das immerhin acht
bis zwölf monate dauern hier kann man
viel schneller reagieren und es wird
eine neue variante im herbst geben
natürlich aber die auswirkung dieser
variante wird im vergleich viel geringer
sein als wenn jetzt noch ein großes
immun loch in der gesellschaft existiert
aber das sehen wir ja eigentlich über 90
prozent der über 60 jährigen geben
die natürliche immunisierung
das wäre die richtige reihenfolge und
dann sind im prinzip alle unser 60 durch
die brauchen sich auch nicht mehr
boostern lassen wenn die über
60-jährigen die anderen wollen
sicherlich sollte man noch nebenzentrum
geben aber wie groß das ihm unseres weiß
keiner und deswegen jetzt über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht zu reden ist
vollständig evidenz befreit da muss man
erst mal ein gutes spiel gestalten und
schauen welche alters und
bevölkerungsschichten tatsächlich noch
eine mutige haben und dann kann man auch
ganz konzentriert und zielgerichtet eine
impfpflicht oder eine impfempfehlung
dann initiieren alles anderes völlig
verstört ich werde den letzten 20
minuten dieser sendung ihnen allerdings
nicht die diskussion über die allgemeine
impfpflicht ersparen können die kommt
nämlich gleich immer frau band bitte
nochmal
ja da sind sich natürlich nicht alle
virologen einig dass es so ist dass
diese varianten jetzt immer milder
würden sondern da scheiden sich durchaus
die geister es gibt auch fachleute die
sagen das kann man einfach nicht
vorhersehen es ist auch gut möglich dass
sich delta wieder ausbreitet oder dass
sich auch wieder eine aggressivere
variante entwickelt in jedem fall aber
möchte ich noch einmal betonen omikron
ist nicht mehr also nur weil diese
variante milder ist als delta und nicht
ganz so viele schwere verläufe auslöst
kann man nicht sagen dass das jetzt
irgend einen schnupfen virus wäre also
auch mit omikron kann man leider immer
noch sehr sehr schwer erkranken vor
allem dann wenn man älter ist oder wenn
man nicht geimpft ist ja dass das finde
ich ganz wesentlich weil das so oft so
verniedlicht wird als hätten wir jetzt
hier aus einem tiger in studen kätzchen
gemacht also so extrem ist der
unterschied dann doch nicht wir haben
jetzt schon mal im laufe dieser sendung
darüber gesprochen was in den köpfen der
menschen vorgeht das heißt im moment
geht es um die lockerungen dass das
leben das zusammenleben wieder
erträglich wird aber ein anderes thema
ist eben die impfpflicht auch
hochaktuell der bundeskanzler ihr
parteifreund termin das hat er heute
gesagt er sei für diese lockerungen die
geschlossen werden im bundestag in
dieser woche er sei aber auch für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht das war ja ein
spektakulärer schwenk den er unternommen
hat kurz vor dem jahreswechsel nur wenn
jetzt lockerungen kommen die recht
weitgehend sind lässt sich dann eine
allgemeine impfpflicht noch glaubwürdig
vertreten natürlich und im übrigen da
verträglich genau die gleiche meinung
wie unser bundeskanzler
denn es passt sehr gut zusammen auf der
einen seite ist die ist die impfung
immer noch das beste mittel um schwere
krankheitsverläufe zu verhindern das
hilft am ende jeder einzelnen person die
sich impfen lässt und das hilft uns als
gesellschaft es hilft das
gesundheitssystem nicht zu überlasten
und weil wir weiterhin lockerungen
machen wollen weil wir schritt für
schritt zur normalität zurückkehren
wollen weil wir keine einschränkungen
mehr wollen ist es so wichtig diese
impfquote weiter zu steigern und deshalb
passt es gut zusammen dass wir schritt
für schritt einschränkungen zurück
zurückfahren und auf der anderen seite
die resilienz die widerstandskraft der
gesellschaft erhöhen und deshalb sagen
wir wir gehen in drei schritten voran
wir werden noch mal massiv informieren
über die gefahren des virus über die
vorteile der impfung wir werden zweitens
beraten
um jedem noch mal individuell ein
gespräch anzubieten um zu gucken wie ist
die eigene situation was kann ich tun
und drittens werden wir vorsorgen um zu
schauen dass sich alle erwachsenen in
deutschland impfen lassen möglichst aus
eigener entscheidung und dann sagen wir
aber wenn das nicht der fall ist das war
jeden in die verantwortung nehmen sich
impfen zu lassen bestimmt die mutmaßlich
werden sie nicht mehr termine zusammen
abstimmen beim thema impfen im bundestag
da gibt es ist ja der fraktionszwang
eigentlich aufgelöst worden in der union
gibt es ein halten sie haben sich aber
der gruppe kubicki angeschlossen also
überhaupt keine impfpflicht
das muss freie entscheidung sein
wenn man jetzt auch auf die zukunft
sieht jetzt die lockerung beim
infektionsschutz möglicherweise gibt es
aber ein virus das da sich doch wieder
durch kämpft und dann dominant wird und
uns möglicherweise im kommenden herbst
und winter ärger machen wird
ist im pflicht oder das impfen nicht
auch eine präventivmaßnahme
auf keinen fall also eine impfpflicht
ist ein eingriff in die körperliche
unversehrtheit und deswegen ist sie auch
verfassungsrechtlich sehr sehr
fragwürdig sie dürfen keine impfpflicht
beschließen für eine mögliche variante
die es heute noch gar nicht gibt für
eine situation die es heute noch gar
nicht gibt das ist verfassungsrechtlich
nicht zu halten davon bin ich fest
überzeugt und deswegen werde ich eine
impfpflicht ablehnen und dagegen stimmen
die sagen die gegend pflichtjahr man
müsse dem stehen sie ja auch positiv
gegenüber noch viel mehr in beratung und
aufklärung investieren um die
impfwilligen dazu bringen sich doch
immer zu lassen ja fragt man sich ja wir
reden nicht nur hier in der phoenix
runde seit über zwei jahren regelmäßig
zu diesem thema wir haben dutzende von
sendungen gemacht und wir sind nicht die
einzigen es gibt jede menge aufklärung
information
trotzdem ist die noch nötig kann ich
daraus resultieren dass die
verschwörungstheorien die davon in
gegner und krone leuten dann verbreitet
werden doch ziemlich erfolgreich waren
in der gesellschaft also zunächst einmal
die das unglaubwürdige vorgehen auch in
der gesamten corona pandemie also
wirklich auch von von von vielen
parteien hat natürlich auch dazu geführt
dass menschen sich irgendwie versuchen
dort halt zu suchen wo sie in meinen zu
finden das ist nicht immer gut ich war
von anfang an der auffassung wir müssen
ehrlich uns mit diesem thema machen die
müssen mit den menschen ehrlich umgehen
und natürlich es war ein neuartiger
impfstoff ja der wurde auf schnellstem
wege zugelassen und es gibt nicht wenige
menschen die tatsächlich auch mit den
folgen der impfung zu kämpfen haben bis
heute auch in meinem persönlichen umfeld
was soll ich sagen ich kann das nicht
wegdiskutieren ich kann doch den
menschen nicht sagen das bildet ihr euch
alles nur ein wir müssen das zur
kenntnis nehmen als politik ist es
unsere aufgabe diese entwicklungen die
da draußen geschehen zur kenntnis zu
nehmen und das beste daraus zu machen
und deswegen bin ich dagegen eine
impfpflicht wir können wir müssen
natürlich fürs impfen werben ohne frage
wenn ein mensch sich aber am ende
dagegen entscheidet dann ist das sein
gutes recht dann ist es dann ist das so
und damit müssen wir auch als politiker
kommen damit müssen wir uns abfinden
da gibt es ja die die diskussion die
einen sagen die sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen oder unsicher sind sie wüssten
nicht welche nebenwirkungen die
impfstoffe haben vor allen dingen der
dna impfstoff auf der anderen seite gibt
es aber bei manchen wohl arabien gruppen
wo viele auch nicht geimpft sind ja die
gefahr long profit zu erleiden das heißt
einen schweren verlauf mit
möglicherweise bleibenden schäden
diese beiden dinge gegeneinander
abzuwägen sind da viele sind ja
offensichtlich der meinung die
nebenwirkungen werden
problematischer obwohl es nicht so viele
jedenfalls statistisch erfasst gibt von
diesen nebenwirkungen aber sehr viele
die massive gesundheitliche probleme
nach nach einer kurve erkrankungen haben
was läuft da in der diskussion
möglicherweise falsch
ja ich glaube das gar nicht so viel in
der diskussion an sich falsch läuft
sondern dass die info dem iwi man ja so
sagt dass also die besten formation
einfach so umfassend ist dass wir
dagegen bislang mit aller aufklärung
nicht angekommen sind also sicherlich
hätte man auch noch viel mehr machen
können noch viel mehr werben und
aufklären können als das geschehen ist
keine frage aber es sind eben auch so
massive kräfte da am werk die zweifel
säen und auch gezielt ja
demokratiefeindliche aktionen betreiben
um die menschen abzuspalten vom staat
das ist schon sehr sehr traurig was da
passiert finde ich weil eben diese
diskrepanz so groß ist also die impfung
ist einfach ein segen und sie kann so
viel leid verhindern und ja es gibt vor
allem impfreaktionen es gibt auch
manchmal nebenwirkungen aber die
infektion mit dem virus ist ungleich
gefährlicher und selbst wenn es manchmal
durch die impfung vielleicht
herzmuskelentzündungen gibt dann ist
über fast aller altersgruppen das risiko
durch das virus sehr viel höherer diese
dinge zu erleiden und wir wissen auch
wie häufig longo wie tesla umso mehr
natürlich bei menschen die schwer
erkrankten die ungeimpft sind von daher
wäre es sinnvoll dass sich viel mehr
menschen in diesem land impfen lassen
herr stöhr ist das ein problem diese
jetzt abwägen zwischen dem recht auf
körperliche unversehrtheit das ist ja
ein grundrecht das im grundrechtskatalog
des grundgesetzes vorzufinden ist auf
der einen seite und auf der anderen
seite schutz von menschen die sich
vielleicht gar nicht impfen lassen
können die aber möglicherweise durch
eine schlechte in squaw erheblich
gefährdet werden also rücksicht auf
andere menschen also eher der frage nach
dem gemeinsinn und nach der
rücksichtnahme ist das ein schwer
vereinbar ist dass diese situation
dieses gegeneinander dieser beiden
aspekte schwer vereinbar
sonst wären wir nicht diskutieren aber
meine politik bei der diskussion 1 man
wird auch den letzten nicht schützen
können vor der infektion sehr wohl habe
der nicht im wege der hoch
immunsupprimierten wird sich auch
infiziert da geht nicht kein weg daran
vorbei was immer man macht dahinten
schien fasste jetzt natürlich der fall
ist dass man immer wieder verlierst es
gibt sehr gute antivirale mittel wenn
die person die ein risiko haben für
einen schweren verlauf die mittel in den
ersten fünf tagen nach der infektion
nehmen und dann auch systematisch jeden
tag weiter die zwei tabletten mehrmals
am tag schlucken das ist auch preislich
liegt um die 500 700 dollar
will ich eigentlich im vergleich dann
kann man 90 prozent der schweren fälle
verhindern also das ist ein tolles
mittel was alle die die und die aus dem
kleinen kreis die sich nicht impfen
lassen können in der hosentasche haben
sollten dann wird man auch in alten
pflegeheimen verwenden kann das in
deutschland auch bald hoffentlich in
größerem umfang zur verfügung steht also
die ins pflicht in meinem meinem
blickwinkel
erfüllt nicht das was man eigentlich
erreichen möchte schon laut über hat
gesagt in deutschland kann man nicht das
handeln weil in deutschland die ihn
fragte der über 60-jährigen zu niedrig
sei über 90 prozent in frankreich
schweden schweiz anderen ländern so bei
21 93 prozent also sind ja nur wenige
prozentpunkte mehr und dann hat auch nie
gesagt wie hoch die in sceaux sein
müsste damit man essen kann den fall
wieder bei der diskussion um die
impfpflicht der wie hoch sollte denn die
impfrate sein dass man eine impfpflicht
braucht und wann brauchte man die
impfpflicht da nichts mehr ab welcher
art gibt es da irgendwelche und oder
hängt man die karotte dann immer höher
und
hat dann überhaupt gar kein parameter
den matten verwendet und das wird auch
die gerichte glaube ich interessieren
und die nach der frage der
verhältnismäßigkeit in front
ja ich würde gern 1 betonen und nochmal
unterscheiden wenn es so häufig heißt es
immer die menschen die sich nicht impfen
lassen können die gibt es fast nicht
also es gibt menschen die aufgrund ihrer
erkrankung oder ihres alters trotz
impfung einen schlechten immunschutz
aufbauen zum beispiel menschen mit
transplantations- organen die eben
bestimmte medikamente nehmen müssen die
imw lassen sich impfen und sind trotzdem
hinterher nicht gut geschützt weil ihr
immunsystem einfach die immunantwort
nicht macht aber es gibt fast keinen der
sich nicht impfen lassen kann aufgrund
irgendwelcher gesundheitlichen
besonderheiten das wird zwar immer mal
wieder erzählt und es gibt selbst ärzte
die das ihren patienten erzählen dass
dem so sei das bei ihnen eine impfung
womöglich gefährlich sei aber wenn man
nicht gerade eine allergie gegen einen
dieser inhaltsstoffe in den impfstoffen
hat dann gibt es im grunde keine
situation dass ich mich nicht impfen
lassen kann sondern führt quasi jeden
menschen mit welcher vorerkrankung auch
immer ist die impfung ein schutz weil er
durch das virus in jedem fall stärker
gefährdet ist als durch die band
die er wisse gar nicht welche impfquote
eigentlich tatsächlich notwendig wäre
damit also sich zu sagen die pandemie
verdrückt gibt es da keine keine zahlen
im moment ist sie dümpelt cia seit
wochen und monaten zu ungefähr 75
prozent das sind nur die zwei impfungen
beim bus dann glaube ich sogar unter 60
prozent
das scheint zu wenig zu sein gibt es
tatsächlich einen ein richtwert einen
zahl an dem man sich orientieren könnte
wie hat sich leider ja immer weiter
hochgeschraubt nicht am anfang hat man
gedacht nach 75 prozent ist toll wenn
wir die haben dann stehen wir gut da nur
dadurch dass wir es inzwischen mit
virusvarianten zu tun haben die ja dem
immunschutz ein stückweit entkommen und
die auch wo die impfung kaum noch gegen
die infektion hilft ist leider dieser
prozentsatz immer mehr gewachsen und man
geht mittlerweile davon aus dass man im
grunde 90 prozent durch impfung bräuchte
um dann wirklich gut die gesamtheit der
menschen zu schützen und dann kommt es
natürlich auf die wohlhabenden gruppen
an dann kommt es darauf an von welcher
impfung reden wir reden wir von
doppelter impfungen ein mittlerweile
reden wir eben auch vom booster als wir
brauchen eigentlich also hohe booster
quoten wenn wir tatsächlich die menschen
umfänglich schützen wollen das müssen
wir vielleicht nicht weil sie irgendwann
auch sagen können jetzt gegen gehen wir
in die eigenverantwortung aber man kann
sagen eigen kann die impfquote gar nicht
hoch genug sein
werden vielleicht auch ganz kurz die
wollte ich etwas sagen noch kurz darauf
antworten ich möchte nämlich noch was
anderes ansprechen bitte ja
die influenza ist höchstwahrscheinlich
werden wird das merken der checker kamen
die vier schwer wiegen der personaler
influenza da ist die diskussion um die
impfpflicht vollständig anders geführt
die gibt es nicht empfiehlt man den
richtigen sich zu helfen weil die
schwangeren frauen leute mit chronisch
obstruktiver moni und ich würde nicht
und so weiter das ist nicht
verhältnismäßig was hier diskutiert wird
im vergleich zu den anderen
atemwegserkrankungen
wird man bei krone endlich wollen unter
anderen die schwerer verlaufen die rsv
erkrankung bei kindern behalten es gibt
mehr kinder auch in den die stationen
krankenhäuser und wegen eines fouls
gegen korona warum auch nicht nur in
deutschland auch in anderen ländern also
wie man hat solche die proportion
verloren und man versucht immer noch
infektionen zu verhindern ich glaube
dass wenn die diskussion in deutschland
weiter auf dieser ebene geführt und
vollständig losgelöst von dem realen
infektions epidemiologischen parameter
an der situation dann wird man weiter
irgendwann mal falsch abgebogen sein und
findet den weg nicht zurück ich schon
erstaunt wir müssen jetzt trotzdem noch
mal auf den bundestag sie sind nicht nur
in unterschiedlichen fraktionen
unterwegs sondern sie haben wir haben ja
schon vorhin angesprochen sie haben auch
sind sozusagen in unterschiedlichen
gruppen anträgen was die impfpflicht
angeht zu sitzen die allgemeine
impfpflicht sozusagen als letzte
konsequenz sie sind gegen die allgemeine
impfpflicht stehen vier modelle zur
diskussion
zur steigerung der impfquote
letztendlich darum geht es ja
ist da überhaupt noch sie haben muss man
auch dazusagen auch weder ihr antrag
noch ihr antrag wird eine mehrheit
erreichen der form wie sind jetzt gerade
präsentieren
ist das einfach noch machbar dass man
sich da auf einen kompromiss einigen der
dann die mehrheit des bundestages der
bundestagsmitglieder findet
also die haltung der kolleginnen und
kollegen
deren antrag ich mich angeschlossen habe
die ist ja unmissverständlich ich wüsste
nicht wo da ein kompromiss zu finden ist
zu den anderen anträgen wir sind gegen
eine impfpflicht wir wollen das nicht
wir wollen gerne werben und versuchen zu
überzeugen aber am ende ist es jeden
seine eigene entscheidung und ich denke
ich glaube sie sind etwas näher oder
werden etwas näher an der absoluten
mehrheit mit ihrem antrag mit der
allgemeinen fliesst sie brauchen aber
verbündete das hat geht nur wenn sie
kompromisse machen wenn sie auf die
anderen zugehen glauben sie dass anfang
april ihren der ersten aprilwoche eine
regelung durch geht in irgendeiner weise
auf das thema impfpflicht in welcher
form auch immer rücksicht nehmen kann
dass man wirklich was am ende bei einer
impfpflicht landet ich bin da
zuversichtlich denn wir haben zwar vier
anträge aber wir haben auf jeden fall
zwei anträge die ganz klar sagen wir
müssen maßnahmen ergreifen damit die
impfquote steigt die modelle sind
unterschiedlich aber im ziel sind wir
uns einig und es gibt dann sogar noch
einen dritten antrag der hat eine art
ich nenne es mal stufenweise eben
schlicht mit verschiedenen dingen die
ein bisschen unrealistisch sind aber
auch in diesem antrag ist ein ansinnen
ablesbar dass man eine höhere impf foto
für erstrebenswert hält und wenn ich an
die vernunft in jedem einzelnen menschen
weiterhin glaube und es tue ich dann bin
ich weiter zuversichtlich dass sich die
menschen dieser drei anträge am ende auf
einen gemeinsamen weg einigen können wo
man sagt was tun wir konkret um einfach
besser vernünftiger für die nächsten
herbst für die nächsten winter
vorbereitet zu sein denn das ist aus
meiner sicht ein weg mit augenmaß
vorzusorgen und der nächsten welle nicht
mehr hinterher zu rennen nur die frage
seid mir dann trotzdem noch mal
gestattet wie soll das denn bitte
durchzusetzen seien schon die
impfpflicht in pflegeeinrichtungen ist
doch gescheitert die menschen die sich
nicht impfen lassen wollen die werden es
auch nach einer impfpflicht nicht tun ja
und insofern sollten wir bei unseren
entscheidungen immer tatsächlich auch
diese gesellschaftliche komponente mit
berücksichtigen dass er in der phoenix
runde auch machen wir bleiben am ball
und passen passen ganz genau auf was
sich im bundestag in der ersten
aprilwoche tun was dabei rauskommt und
auch ob das umgesetzt werden kann ich
bin nämlich bei ihnen bei einer schimke
bei matthias mewes bei christina berndt
und bei klaus staeck die zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer das nächste phoenix
gesprächsformat ist am montag 22.15
unter den linden mit michaela kolster
jetzt folgt für nix der tag mit mayer
weber darin unter anderem der doch
ziemlich spektakuläre auftritt des
ukrainischen präsidenten wolodimir
selensky heute vormittag im deutschen
bundestag live zugeschaltet aus kiew
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]